good morning down today has to be an
update there's just too much going on so
update in nine parts starting now
shooting The Fault in Our Stars movie is
wrapping up and while I have really
enjoyed this really unique
behind-the-scenes look from the
perspective of a total newb that is you
kind of glad to have you back cuz
somebody needs to explain dead ceilings
to me part two subbable is doing
amazingly wheezy waiters on there now
mystery guitar man
PGP great minutephysics beard board
Gades woodworking for mere mortals all
you woodworking fans out there subbable
for the last two months has averaged a
hundred thousand dollars a month paid
out to partners three I've been in
several recent episodes of wheezy
waiters the good stuff there's links in
the description bar I'm headed to
Sanford's
from Daily Grace which is super weird I
have I did not expect
I'm trying to open this with a staple
remover gonna stab it with a pen oh my
god that's us really soft
scissors they were there they were there
the whole time if it's something to
drink says a belated gift to say thank
you for a wonderful VidCon this is
amazing oh my god it is a drink its
Hendrix I can't believe I called it also
mmm
sweetheart anyway I was saying I'm going
to San Francisco for an edu conference
at YouTube I'm excited for good ideas
and things seem to be a Records is going
well here I am at the warehouse we're
getting ready for Christmas and also the
Lizzie Bennet Kickstarter which I'm
sorry we haven't sent out yet but at the
moment there's not a lot to do actually
have a new vlog series called the
warehouse starring one of our warehouse
workers Matthew he films right over here
and this is the fort he built out of
overstock boxes
it's called fort awesome I didn't really
put this one these are all still signed
we still have lots of signed John Green
posters here quite a while ago I sat
right here and I told you about my idea
for turning Jane Austen book into a
video blog series that thing the Lizzie
Bennet diaries did very well
tens millions of views won an Emmy I'm
excited to sit here again and tell you
that we're doing it again this time with
Jane Austen's Emma I think they're
telling stories in different ways is
really fascinating and we're going to
continue exploring that probably in some
more new different exciting ways but
you'll have to go to youtube.com slash
Pemberley digital to watch and see what
we're up to thank you to all of you who
love
in support of the Lizzie Bennet diaries
I really hope that you like Emma
approved as well also John and I are
helping out with the Harry Potter
alliances equality for the win IndieGoGo
campaign there are a bunch of really
great perks there's an excerpt from the
price of Dom the fictional novel from
The Fault in Our Stars written by John
hair Potter fan fit called the womb of
requirement which is like an origin
story for the Room of Requirement going
to be read into like an audiobook kind
of thing by Evanna Lynch yeah it will be
available for not very much longer a
midnight Pacific Time Saturday yes
there's a lot going to be on it to be
honest I'm a little fret a lot going to
be on yep take on maybe a couple more
responsibilities than I should
occasionally but I feel like I have like
responsibilities to the world you John
into nerdfighteria and I you know I
really appreciate that I have
opportunities to do all these cool
things and how can you say no and then
sometimes you just get somebody being
really nice and sending you gin oh great
those more like daily disgraceful oh
yeah lots of stuff going on if you're
having a hard time following it we are
on whatever social network you prefer
newly Google+ I've talked about a lot of
things in this video there's links to
all of them in the description John I'll
see you on Tuesday
gather just got back from the dentist
how's your face what face mop mop mop
mop I'll go watch a show grades are my
potatoes okay Pat Park hate house Oh
dick you're gay DOS
[Music]